let's keep going you want to keep going
on the insanity train once you're on the
insanity train that's the thing once you
are on the msnbc
trained to bonkersville it's hard to get
off that train here's joy reid talking
to our vice president who is one broken
hip away from being the most powerful
person in the world about uh katanji
brown jackson
and uh her hearings when the republicans
were being very very mean to her
obviously because she's black
we all sat and watched the katanji brown
jackson uh hearings uh in which she
very calmly um sat through what i think
a lot of particularly black women let's
just be honest felt was brazen
disrespect from senators like lindsey
graham senators like tom cotton senators
like josh hawley
what did you think when you watch that
hearing
i will tell you
joy
i experienced great
joy
when i watched this brilliant
phenomenal
black woman
jurist
be so smart
and just cut through
the political gamesmanship
that they were attempting to
incite and she just was composed
and as far as i'm concerned was taking a
whole lot of people to school
and i watched that with incredible joy
because it was just brilliance
being displayed
for the entire country to see
and i cannot wait to see i it that will
only be matched by the joy
that i experience
when i see her take the oath
to be the next justice on the united
states supreme court
those are clown people i don't care
about the color of their skin and i
don't care about their gender those are
not serious people those are ridiculous
people that woman should not be the vice
president of the united states that
other person should not be on television
paid by a giant corporation to bring
news but she's very proud because she
was you know she was really great in the
face of all the racism and the mean
stuff that they said and all that she
schooled them she's cooled them we've
got some video of the schooling
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me a
definition
dave don't do that that selectively
edited videotape to make it seem like
she doesn't know what a woman is there
must be video of her schooling mean
people like white supremacist ted cruz
for example i'm i'm an hispanic man
could could i decide i was an asian man
would i have the ability to be an asian
man
and challenge harvard's discrimination
because i made that decision
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and um i'm asking you how
you would assess standing if i if i came
in and said i have decided i identify as
an asian man
damn
yo she schooled cruz cruz is busted man
he's done he's out that's it she's
composed and she cry